pour la reprise de l'entraînement à
l'école de football du stade auxerrois
l'effet coupe du monde se voit aux
maillots portés par les enfants pour la
plupart d'entre eux c'est une grande
première ils n'ont jamais joué en club
ils ont vu à la télé griezmann et un
bape et devenir champion du monde
quelques mois après les voici à leur
tour sur la pelouse du foot avec quels
joueurs
[Musique]
aujourd'hui il fallait faire la queue
pour s'inscrire et pour les parents pas
de doute l'équipe de france et la coupe
du monde ont séduit leur enfant oui
c'est un effet l'horizon suivi la coupe
du monde à fond je crois que dans toutes
les écoles les gamins des terrains font
aussi excité devant l'équipe de france
et regarde comment ils jouent alors
voilà il souhaite vraiment d'être comme
et pourtant c'est ce qu'ils voulaient
faire quand il ya des la télé donc la
coupe du monde comme pas mal de monde et
voilà il a vu ça donc il voulait il
voulait faire du ballon donc on l'a
inscrit pour jouer c'est quoi pas pour
cette reprise
ils étaient plus d'une cinquantaine
d'enfants garçons et quelques filles
avec surtout 70% de nouveau une aubaine
pour ce club amateur avec vos événements
et des relais grande victoire il ya
toujours un petit effet que l'on
retrouve sur le terrain pour nous c'est
ultra bénéfique parce que ça nous
rapporte des licenciés on a un club
amateur donc on vit essentiellement par
le par le football de masse autre
terrain autre école de foot mais
toujours le même engouement cheval
enregistre lui aussi 30% de nouveau une
vraie bouffée d'oxygène pour ce petit
club et ses 200 licenciés c'est surtout
une obligation pour nous aimer du catr
d'arriver à les conserver au club pour
les futures années et d'en faire
j'espère nos seniors dans sept huit neuf
ans et qui seront la relève et la relève
des dirigeants aussi peut-être quatre
heures les jeunes qui viennent d'arriver
vous aurez les prochains en disant
prochain bénévoles du club à la ville
comme à la campagne
griezmann de l'équipe de france ont fait
partout des émules
l'objectif désormais pour les clubs de
l'yonne sera de surfer sur la vague
bleue pour garder tous ces jeunes
[Musique]